welcome back you're watching in King
life in the heart of the city it's a
knockout at least it will be financially
what's being billed as the most
lucrative fight ever will finally take
place in the early hours of Sunday two
men considered among the best ever
pound for pound fighters Floyd
Mayweather and Manny Pacquiao will take
each other on in Las Vegas the paychecks
for each fighter are reported 117
million dollars for Mayweather while his
Filipino opponent has a smaller but says
still substantial share of the prize
fund of what's believed to be 78 million
pounds it's fair to say that tickets
aren't going cheaply won sites had
ringside seats on offer today at two
hundred and twenty seven thousand pounds
and with an expected three million
spectators at home potential
pay-per-view revenue is close to two
hundred million pounds well Tom Scott is
from the sports marketing and
sponsorship agency rep you common joins
me now Tom for those who aren't okay
with boxing why is it such a huge fight
this is such a huge fight we've got two
of the best pound-for-pound boxes of a
generation coming together it should
have happened probably five years ago
let's say it's been in the pipeline for
about five years but it's all about
supply and demand as this market and
it's all about hype and they've done it
so well over the last five years that
finally on May the second we're gonna
see these two come together yeah now
this is a great moment for boxing it's a
big big fight as you say but I mean
genuinely boxing thought to be on a bit
of a downward trajectory compared with
the sort of golden days of Ollie Fraser
and Foreman in the 70s and then more
laterally in the 1980s the likes of Mike
Tyson you go along with us to some
extent to some extent let's not forget
that this match this fight is so big
because there are enough people that
want to watch it we're taking this look
at the US for example US and Canada
alone three million pay-per-view sales
already already before the second of May
that's equivalent to about 300 million
dollars we look at Europe or the rest of
the world another 35 million dollars if
the people didn't want to watch this we
wouldn't have these sort of soapbox is
it on its way out no it's not and this
is the reason why and yet this is quite
an exceptional fight I mean Vladimir
Klitschko though the world heavyweight
didn't sell out Madison Square Garden
last week
and that was a title defense and that
kind of shows us the difference between
how boxing sets itself apart to
something that you have seen for example
we don't have the lead structures that
we do have these other competitions
that's not to say that when you can put
the right boxes together with the right
promoters the right circumstances this
is exactly what we've got we can look at
it through social media for example this
week so we've had 65% of the chatter has
been towards Mayweather we've had the
9.5 fans that Mayweather's got the 6.5
million Facebook fans that Pacquiao is
got it's an incredible moment for the
sport that is going to be something very
special not just for this event because
of course one of these books is going to
walk away with a WBO WBA WBC who's gonna
walk away of nothing yeah they're both
in their late 30s how do they then or
one of them then carry on that legacy
yeah Mayweather cuz he's never been
beaten exactly and of course Pacquiao's
team will want the spear forty seven and
one but I think people's hearts will
want Pacquiao for sure people's heads I
think will still be going for Mayweather
yeah that's really interesting City I
mean whilst Mayweather gets a bigger
share of the purse Pacquiao's got more
short sponsors for the fight why is that
well so Evert become what we do is we
have a look at public perception of
these two or number of service you have
7,000 we look at but let's look at the
US alone in five years ago for example
the awareness of these two boxers was
very different today we've got Manny
Pacquiao looking about 63% of the
American population know who he is if we
look at Mayweather 66 percent however
when we look at a little bit further
into the detail more people like
Pacquiao he has a greater appeal has
greater trust and that reflects back
into sponsorship so he's got six
sponsors on his shorts I don't know
where they're gonna fit them but we'll
see as opposed to Floyd's one and that
was only signed this this week so it's a
Fanjul sponsorship you know Pacquiao is
is likable he's quiet he's reserved he
comes money to the poor yeah he's got
charities he's a lot more alike or so I
think people out there the majority the
neutrals that say will certainly want
the Filipino but I think it might be
me bein what made with alright Tom Scott
good to see you thanks for joining us
and that's all we've got time for but
before I go did you work out the story
behind my number of the day and that was
160 billion euros and that was the son
invested by German households last year
the irony is that the rest of the world
would rather they had spent that money
rather than saved it you've been
watching in King life if you missed any
of today's interviews they're all on the
Sky News for iPad app next up Sky News
Tonight with Adam Bolton live in Leeds
with the build-up to that last leaders
TV debate I'll be back again tomorrow at
some point hope to see you then thanks
for watching good night
you